a chicago police dispatcher who was once
praised by mayor lori lightfoot now
speaking truth to power and sounding off
over the rising crime and the shortage
of cops
it's outrageous
and i'm not happy when you say chicago
people are afraid
it looks like it's a death zone several
of my officers who texted me okay um
and said that they were scared
they're tired of this nonsense they have
no backing and they're scared of being
out there by themselves this mayor does
not care about chicago police officers
period she doesn't care about any first
responders she doesn't care about the
damn city
and the dispatcher wasn't done calling
out the mayor
at all hours of the day there is a
massive amount of crime taking place
within the city of chicago and i mean
it's horrendous people are being shot
killed our citizens deserve more backing
out there and the acknowledgement that
things are going on and action needs to
be taken and more importantly our first
responders not just the police but fire
department ems the dispatchers call
takers that are out here doing these
wonderful jobs they have absolutely no
backing they're being overworked and
with the shortages going on right now
it's only affecting the citizens of
chicago
it's just so disheartening to hear this
joey let me go to you first because a
lot of the men and women who wear the
badge that i've talked to a lot of them
were veterans as well and they they
described what it's like being in the
streets of chicago and a lot of the the
blue cities these days as like being in
a foxhole under fire and you're calling
for helicopter support and there's just
nothing coming back
in in your experience when you when you
look at these cities can you is there
any advice you can give these men and
women who are in these situations who
are basically left they're just their
their sixes are just not covered
you know everybody hates a bad cop
everybody hates anybody in position of
authority who would abuse it or or use
that even casually to talk down to
someone or or put them
in a corner and i hate that feeling
myself but the majority of cops when i
say majority i mean my belief is my
presumption when a cop walks up to me is
that's not the case and for any cop out
there veteran or not remember why you
took the job remember why you put the
badge on it wasn't for the pay it
obviously wasn't for the glory it was
because you felt like you could do
something to make your community better
and if every single one of the cops out
there that believe that and join for
that reason act that way i don't think
politicians will have the opportunity to
continue to undermine them because
communities will support them that's
what i think
well well said bro well said richard i i
go to you when you hear some of the
things that mayor lightfoot has has said
and practiced when you look at you know
in the democratic scheme of things she
didn't want help from the previous
administration you know she said that
merchants and retailers need to do a
better job it's their fault that the
crime rate's high she won't speak to
reporters unless they're a person of
color when you hear all these missteps
and the optics of this how hard is it as
a democrat to be able to just get behind
any of this or is this just something
i'm missing
no i don't think you're missing anything
here i have no love loss for uh mayor
lloyd lightfoot of chicago i think that
she has done a dismal job of leading the
city not only do we have an increase in
crime but she's also failed to talk to
members of the north and the south and
west side of the city she promised to be
a candidate that would unite the city
and deal with income inequality and deal
with the disparities that exist on the
south and west side of the city and
she's failed at that miserably she
failed to implement a testing and
contact tracing policy even though the
biden administration gave her over 1.8
billion dollars in our public schools in
the city of chicago and as a result of
that there was a school just a couple
weeks ago in the city of chicago jensen
elementary that witnessed an outbreak
that caused two mothers to die of covet
19 and this is all happening on the
mayor's watch and she has admitted that
she has failed when it comes to
implementing a policy to decrease the
spread of kova 19 in her city so shame
on mary mayor lori lightfoot and big ups
to all the people who are fighting
against her on the southwest side of
chicago
dr nicole i mean for lack of a better
term diagnosis murder it's up 68
in in chicago when you hear these kind
of numbers you know and and i'm
literally and i'm kid you not at one
point someone said yes but attempted
murder is down i don't even know how to
even tackle that when you look at these
numbers of violence and crimes where do
you think the best way for chicago to
start to turn this around
well that's right tyra so uh coba deaths
are down 30 in chicago but their
homicides and shootings are up 60
percent and you know public safety is a
fundamental responsibility of the local
government and so when you see cities
like chicago that is high in crime this
is a direct failure of the elected
officials and the policies being
implemented and people are starting to
see that elections have consequences so
when you have a city like this high in
crime and low in health because you have
police officers because of under funding
that are retiring or they are quitting
you know this puts people in a very
precarious situation and you are going
to see more violent violence perhaps
president biden dr fauci etiol should
start focusing on this public health
crisis because this is the one that is
rapidly expanding that there is no end
in sight to and spend a little less time
on covet
yeah that's a great point rachel final
thoughts
amen to that dr sapphire more children
have died of gunfire in chicago than
covid for sure i'll say this was
powerful because this was a dispatcher
dispatchers get the calls the 911 calls
and have to make the heartbreaking
decisions you know to send out
responders and then if there's not
enough cops they have to let those
people in distress know so this man
knows what he's talking about and that's
why he's out there and it's really
powerful that he is i lived in third
world countries my father was in the
military and when i was in those
countries there wasn't enough funding
for for law enforcement there and it was
rich people who were able to you know
have their own private security and
their own
basically fortresses around their house
we're seeing that now in cities like
chicago and los angeles rich people um
you know mitigating you know
uh uh basically covering their bases
their houses um with with private
security and then it's the poor people
who are left um to deal with this crime
we are turning our country our our
biggest cities into third world
countries and it's done deliberately it
doesn't have to be this way the funding
is there she's just choosing not to give
it to law enforcement and safety
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else